Mr. Clifford: I'm Mr. Clifford... and this
is Adriene Hill, welcome to Crash Course economics.
Let's start by talking about something that
most people take for granted.
Adriene: Is it grocery stores, is it the census,
is it GPS, is it goldfish, is it frogs? Oh,
it's probably these strawberries, right?
Mr. Clifford: No, I was gonna say markets.
Adriene: But, strawberries are great.
Mr. Clifford: Yeah, but where do you think
strawberries came from?
Adriene: The ground, the farmer, the market,
the grocery store, the miracle of life?
Mr. Clifford: Now look around you. Where did
all that stuff come from? And who made it?
And why? Well, the answer is simple, but it's
underrated. It's markets, and for most of
us farms and factories and stores, but mainly
it's just markets. Can I have a strawberry now?
[Theme Music]
Adriene: So a market is any place where buyers
and sellers meet to exchange goods and services.
The key to markets is the concept of voluntary
exchange. That is, that buyers and sellers
willingly decide to make a transaction.
Let's say you go to a farmer's market and
you buy a box of strawberries for $3. You
value the box of strawberries more than the
$3 you gave up to get it. The seller valued
the $3 more than the box of strawberries.
The transaction's a win-win because you got
your strawberries and the farmer got his money.
You both felt better off; that's voluntary exchange.
This same process happens in the labor market.
Say that instead of the farmer's market, you
bought your strawberries at your local supermarket.
The cashier voluntarily decided to work there.
He values the $10 an hour he makes there more
than he does sitting at home watching the
Walking Dead. At the same time, the owner
of the store values the labor of the cashier
more than the $10 an hour she pays him.
And so it goes, on and on, all the way up
the chain of production, from the driver that
delivered the strawberries to the farmer that
grew the strawberries to the tractor that
the farmer purchased. The point is that markets are
everywhere and most are based on voluntary exchange.
Mr. Clifford: The part of all this that most
people take for granted is how efficient the
system is. Competitive markets turn out to
be pretty great about allocating or distributing
our scarce resources towards their
most efficient use.
So if farmers produce, like, too many strawberries,
then the price will fall as sellers try to
sell them off. Lower prices means less profit
for the strawberry farmers, and those farmers
will have an incentive to produce something
else like lettuce or Brussels sprouts. So
if farmers don't produce enough strawberries,
buyers will bid up the price and the farmers
will have an incentive to produce more, which then
drives down the price. That's like magic except it's not.
The information that markets generate to guide
a distribution of resources is what economists
call price signals. Markets also incentivize
the production of high-quality products. If
the strawberries are brown and nasty then
no one's gonna want to buy them, and if the
tractor's a piece of junk, the strawberry farmer's
gonna tell other farmers to buy some other tractor.
Now, ideally the eventual result of voluntary
exchange is that sellers can't make themselves
better off without making something that makes
buyers better off.
Businesses, and in particular large corporations,
are often villainized as greedy, heartless
institutions that take advantage of consumers,
but if markets are transparent and buyers
are free to choose, then businesses will have
a hard time taking advantage of people.
Now obviously greed and deception happen in
real life, and there are situations where
consumers don't have a choice, but for the
most part, if you really don't like the policies
or practices of a particular company, then
don't shop there. After all, in the free market,
every dollar that is spent signals to producers what
should be produced and how it should be produced.
Adriene: We've established that prices and
profit determine where resources should go,
but where do prices come from? Who determines
the price of my box of strawberries? To answer
that, we're gonna draw - get ready for it
- supply and demand. Let's go to the runway.
Mr. Clifford: If there's only one thing you
should learn in economics, it's supply and
demand. Let's use the market for strawberries
to help us understand this concept. Up here
on the Y axis, we have the price of strawberries,
down here on the X axis we have the quantity of boxes of strawberries.
Let's start by looking at buyers and how they
respond to a change in price. If the price
goes up for strawberries, then some buyers
will go buy blueberries or they'll go on that
all bacon diet. The point is, they're gonna
buy less strawberries. And if the price goes
down for strawberries, then people are gonna
buy more. This is called the law of demand:
when the price goes up, people buy less, when
the price goes down, people buy more. On the
graph it's show by a downward sloping demand
curve.
Now let's think about sellers like the farmer
in the farmer's market. If the price of strawberries
go up, then that farmer will make more profit,
so will have an incentive to produce more
strawberries. If the price goes down then
he's not gonna want to produce strawberries.
That's called the law of supply, and on the
graph it's shown by an upward sloping supply curve.
Now let's put supply and demand together.
If the price is really high at $10 then producers
would like to produce a lot of strawberries,
but consumers won't want to buy them. This
mismatch is called a surplus. And if the price
goes down for strawberries, let's say down
to $1, then buyers want to buy a whole lot,
but producers won't have incentive and they'll
produce very little. At the end you have mismatch,
but this one's called a shortage.
And there's only one price where the quantity
that buyers want to buy is exactly equal to
the quantity that sellers want to sell, and
it's right here where supply equals demand.
The price is called the equilibrium price,
and the quantity is called the equilibrium quantity.
Adriene: Okay, sure your graph makes sense,
but the price of strawberries isn't always
$3; sometimes it goes up to $6, and at Whole
Foods, local, artisanally grown strawberries,
the fancy fancy strawberries, can cost upwards
of $12. But I guess Whole Foods is a whole
other world where price has nothing to do
with realistic economics. We'll stick to normal
strawberries. In fact, the prices for all
sort of stuff change all the time.
External forces can shift both the supply
and demand curves, changing the equilibrium
price and quantity. For example, let's assume
that this graph shows the demand and supply
of strawberries in the summer. What happens
in the winter? Will the change in weather
affect buyers' demand? Or producers supply?
Spoiler alert: it's supply. Colder temperatures
make it harder to grow strawberries. The result
is the entire supply curve is gonna shift to the left.
This is because at all possible prices, there'd
be fewer strawberries produced. That's it.
This graph is just a tool that economists
and everyone else used to show the results
of a change in a market. I know it seems complicated
at first, but there are really only four things
that can happen in a market.
Supply can decrease, supply can increase,
demand can decrease, or demand can increase.
Some people might wanna talk about a price
being fair or right. Well, that all depends
on your point of view. The buyer always considers
a low price to be a very fair price, while
the seller considers it unfair and vice versa.
In general, economists don't really like to
push opinions about prices. Voluntary exchange
suggests that the price is there for a reason.
For example, assume the demand for strawberries
inexplicably falls, so the demand curve shifts
to the left and the equilibrium price and
quantity fall. Farmers might go to the government
for assistance, but most economists would
argue there's no reason to bail them out.
The market's spoken. Strawberries are so over.
Furthermore, if the government helps the farmers
by giving them a subsidy, it would be putting
resources towards something that society doesn't
value. That would be inefficient. Luckily,
every reasonable person on Earth values strawberries,
so they continue to get produced.
Mr. Clifford: Now, the downside is, the supply
and demand model only applies to analyzing
strawberries. Nah, I'm just joking; it applies
to all sorts of stuff. In fact, let's look
at a market for a commodity known for its
volatility, both because of its fluctuating
prices and because sometimes, it explodes:
gasoline.
Now when you see gas prices are moving all
over the board, that's just demand and supply.
For example, in 2014, the retail gas price
in the United States fell dramatically. Why?
Well, it was demand and supply. The economies
of both Europe and China weakened, which decreased
the demand for gasoline, shifting the demand
curve to the left. At the same time, new fracking
technology and restored production of oil
in Iraq and Libya caused the supply of gasoline
to increase, or shift to the right. The combination
drove gas prices down by more than 40% per
gallon. And that's it. Now you can tell all
your friends you understand supply and demand.
It's a big day for you. It's a big day.
Adrienne: So markets and supply and demand
are awesome. But sometimes, they're not awesome.
For example, we don't wanna use the market
approach when it comes to firefighters.
[Phone rings]
911, what's your emergency?
Mr. Clifford: My house is on fire, how much
do you charge to put it out?
Adrienne: It'll be $10,000, what's your credit
card number?
Mr. Clifford: They're all melted!
Adrienne: [hangs up] Okay, that one's obvious,
but what about the market for human organs?
After all, there's a huge shortage, and thousands
of people die each year waiting for transplants.
Should there be a competitive market for human
kidneys? A free marketeer would say sure,
why not? If a donor wants $15,000 more than
he wants his other kidney, why stop him?
Mr. Clifford: Well. Ethics. I mean, there's
several problems that arise with an unregulated
market for human kidneys. First is the moral
question, is it fair for a poor person who
can't afford a kidney to die while a rich
person lives? Well, probably...no, not at
all. Another problem results in the law of
supply. When there's an increase in the price
of kidneys, there's an incentive for people
to steal and sell kidneys. In fact, the World
Health Organization has stated, "Payment for
organs is likely to take unfair advantage
of the poorest and most vulnerable groups,
undermines altruistic donations, and leads
to profiteering and human trafficking. I mean,
all bad things. Now, that being said, why
do 70% of American economic association members
support some kind of payment for organ donors?
Adrienne: Well, it's because you can solve
some of these problems with a market approach,
but the market must be regulated. Often family
and friends are willing to donate a kidney,
but they're not a match for the patient. Economists
generally support creating kidney exchanges,
where pairs of willing donors are matched
with strangers that agree to donate to each
others' loved ones. In both cases, the supply
of donated kidneys would increase, which would
alleviate some of the shortage. Like we've
said before, free markets are awesome, but they
can't solve all our problems Sometimes, they need to
be regulated, and sometimes, they should be avoided.
So there you have what, for most people, is
the start and for many, the end of economics.
Supply and demand. Economists and politicians
often like to refer to the interaction of
supply and demand as laws, and we've done
that too, but to be clear, it's not an absolute
law, like the law of gravity.
Mr. Clifford: As we've tried to point out
here on Crash Course, economics is about human
choices and their consequences. Even though
supply and demand behave in a predictable
way that we've seen in the models, we can't
lose sight of the fact that both of them are
reliant on humans acting as buyers and sellers.
Adrienne: Our actions influence supply and
demand in a way that they can't influence
gravity, no matter how much we might want
to.
Mr. Clifford: Whoa.
Adrienne: That's After Effects. And that's
something to keep in mind when you hear us
or anybody talking about economic laws. Thanks
for watching. We'll see you next time.
Mr. Clifford: Thanks for watching Crash Course
Economics, it was made with the help of all
these nice people . You demanded it, and they
supplied it. Now, if you want them to keep
supplying it, please head over to Patreon.
It's a voluntary subscription platform that
allows you to pay whatever you want monthly
to help make Crash Course free for everyone
forever. Thanks for watching. DFTBA.